Let me show you how to use Dreamflow's
Git integration. First, we'll clone a
repository from a private repo on
GitHub. And then we'll walk through how
to push a DreamFlow project you've been
working on to a new GitHub repo. For
this tutorial, we'll be using GitHub,
but this will work with any Git provider
like GitLab or Bitbucket. Okay, let's
get started. So, to clone a repo, just
come over here to clone codebase. Now,
the repo I'm going to be using is the
Great Wondrous app that I forked from
GSK. So, give it a name. And now we're
going to go grab the repo URL and get
our access token. To get your URL, just
come over here to code and in the HTTPS
and just grab this. Let's paste that in.
And I'll get our access token. To get
that, come over to your profile and into
settings and scroll down on the bottom
left here to developer settings. Then go
to personal access tokens. And you can
use either fine grain or the classic
tokens. We've left a link to the
documentation below. We're just going to
do classic tokens. Then let's generate a
new token. Give it a name. Set your
expiration date. We'll just keep it at
the default. And select the scopes of
permission that DreamFlow will have
access to. You'll need to give it the
repo and workflow. Then you can scroll
down and generate the token. Keep in
mind that you only see this token once.
So copy it and then go back to
DreamFlow. Paste in your token and clone
your repository. Now, how long this will
take will depend on the size of the
project. So, just keep that in mind if
you've got a larger project. Beautiful.
Our app is loaded up and running. Okay,
let's go over to our source control
section here where we can see the
history of our commits, any current
changes, and controls for branches and
connections to our source. Okay, this is
looking good. So, let's make some
changes here. I want to increase the
size of this text. It's a little bit
small. So, I'm going to go in here and
doubleclick down through the widget tree
until I get to my component here. There
it is. And I'm just going to do a quick
edit right here. Command K. Increase the
size of the font.
Yeah, that's looking better. And you can
see changes are automatically tracked
here. So, when you're ready to commit,
you can write a commit message right
here. Or you can have the agent do it
simply by selecting this button right
here. adjust drop cap sizing for better
readability. Yeah, that makes sense. But
let's be a little bit cleaner with this
and instead of committing it straight to
main, let's open up a new branch here.
We're going to call this font legibility
and save. Now we've switched to this
branch right there. We can see and let's
commit and push these changes. Here we
can see our commits been added. But
let's jump over to GitHub and take a
look. You can do so by just clicking on
this right here. You can see we've got
our two branches. And if we select them,
you can see there's our commit we just
made. Now, as our team has been working,
a colleague made some changes, too. A
colleague was working on this, too. And
I'm going to pull in his changes. So,
I'm going to go here and pull in changes
from remote. And you can see down here,
we've got some conflicts. So, we can
select it here. And if we scroll down,
we can see the familiar UI. And I'm
actually going to keep the ones that I'm
working with. Okay, great. That's
resolved. And if you want to see what
branches are available to you, you can
go in this dropown here and refresh your
branches. Let's jump over to a new
project, one that we started in
DreamFlow, and see how we get it into
version control. So I've got this
dashboard app, and I want to hook it up
to version control here. So I want to
connect a repository, and I need the
same information as before. So let's go
set that up in GitHub. So let's come
over here to add a new repo. Choose an
owner, a repo name, and make sure to add
a read or a license. the repo can't be
empty. So, I'm going to add a readme
right here and create the repository.
Okay. Then we go through the same
process right here. So, I'm going to
grab the URL and paste in our access
token and connect. All right. Great. We
are connected now. So, let's make our
first commit. We'll use it with the AI
and push our changes. Okay. Next, let's
add a feature here. And we'll use one of
the features generated from the agent
already. So, we're going to add a
settings page. And you can see while the
agent is working, it's automatically
tracking changes. Okay, the agent is
done. We've got our changes tracked
here. Let's go look at the feature.
Okay, this is looking good except for we
just got this border here. So, let's
just remove this real quick. I'm going
to click into here, go up to my card, do
a quick edit, remove border. Okay,
that's great.
And let's remove one other border right
here.
remove border. Okay, that's great. All
right, let's generate our commit message
and push our changes. This way of
working with Git allows you to manage
your projects efficiently. And if you
need to run external scripts like buildr
runner, you can do that in your editor
of choice and just pull those changes
in. Let us know if you have any
questions and we'll see you in the next
video.